troy what is the most difficult part of
producing a reality show
the most difficult part of producing a
reality show in the beginning
is setting a tone for that show and
understanding how that show is supposed
to feel
because what will happen is a network
will commit to your show they want to
see it
if you're doing a show for usa it's
going to have a very specific feel if
you're doing a show for cbs
they have a different demographic they
want to hear what they want to hear if
you're doing a show for we
or for own everybody has their own
laundry list
of stuff that you have to be able to hit
you also
are in the strange position where you
need to create something that feels
familiar
but is different enough that it stands
apart from the other content on that
network
so oftentimes turning in the first
episode
is a real ordeal because you're really
trying to figure out how to please
the network both creatively as far as
giving them something fresh and
something new and something that's also
on the other hand familiar
as far as selling a reality show and
getting a reality show to air
it's just a matter of trying to hit that
sweet spot of what the network
really needs they don't always
articulate what it is that they need
very often you'll get a call or an email
from your agent that says
you know so-and-so is buying this you
read the cable updates and you say well
so-and-so bought a couple of these you
know shows about
chefs so i better start thinking about
that space for that network because it
looks like they're starting to do more
cooking
oriented stuff even though it's a
channel that's never done that before
it's just trying to it's trying to
predict the need
is is very difficult that's the other
hardest thing as far as trying to sell
something is predicting what the needs
are
and sustaining that throughout the
additional episodes
yeah trying to find a place to go in a
show that isn't
a particularly well thought out thing
there are a lot of shows that sell
based on the idea of the show versus
what you can actually execute
if i told you that i wanted to do a real
life version
of 30 rock
and i was going to follow these writers
in the writers room and it was going to
be amazing
as a concept that sounds like fun it's
like hey there's a bunch of funny people
that work on a tv show and i'm going to
do a real life version of them in the
writer's room
a writer's room is brutal
and it's just people working things out
and bashing stuff out and putting cards
on the wall and they're in one room
and they order all their food in because
they don't have time to go out and
they're going to eat everything out of
tins
and solve problems and look at notes and
complain about stuff and you're and
it's not a show that's going to be super
exciting and whiz-bang and a lot of
action
so as a concept sounds great and
in practice it doesn't right that
million-dollar napkin idea
it's the million-dollar napkin idea is
if it's if you can't execute it
you it just don't even go there right
interesting but you sometimes you get
saddled with what what i was trying to
say really was
sometimes you get saddled with a show
like that where there's almost no way to
get a positive outcome
those shows are actually in a way a lot
of fun because
trying to figure out the solution
it's like the biggest rubik's cube ever
you